aren't the battle to stop the spread of
coronavirus having an immediate negative
impact on businesses from Wall Street to
Main Street and everywhere in between so
the White House has been working
feverishly with the Senate this week to
try to get relief to Americans who need
it as soon as possible
employees well the message is that this
was something that happened it's
nobody's fault it happened and we're
gonna take care of it
managing partner of the hill Restaurant
Group Tom Johnson is already
experiencing this reality he joins us
live to talk about it Tom good to have
you with us I know you because I've read
about your story that you employ a lot
of people you care about them
individually you know about them but
this policy now in DC that has been
rolled out means real trouble for you
tell us your situation
well hello Shannon it's been very tough
I mean you know all of a sudden
overnight we get told that we pretty
much have to shut down I mean the first
roll out was that we had the limits
eating and which would have pretty much
put us out of business
and with the new shutdown pretty much I
have 150 employees that I had to pretty
much furlough immediately you know we
just come out of the slow season in DC
so you know we're it's not like we're
flush with cash going into the season so
this is what we usually make our money
right because this is the time of year
for folks who don't know our cherry
blossoms bloom we get a ton of tourism
that pours in this time of year and it
does light up our restaurants and
theaters and everything else are you
able to do anything with being able to
provide delivery or carryout you know I
know a lot of restaurants are trying to
do that to string together some work is
it a possibility for you most of our
restaurants are set up for that we're
more dime in we're actually just trying
to figure out how to proceed right now
with you know with DC government right
now is doing I think they passed some
things too late this evening haven't
really got to read up on them yet but
we're it's I know it's definitely
supporting the workforce you know our
big concern with this whole shutdown was
our employees we were trying to hang on
to them as long as possible I actually
got in a little tiff with the mayor you
did
and you know she when she was initially
rolling these things out you had said no
I have employees to pay and they have
families to feed and I'm gonna do
everything I can to stay open and she
basically said I'm not giving you an
option this is the policy and you got to
do it
yeah the Wendy first rolled out the
first proposal which would had limited
seating with six feet apart and no bar
seating most of our you know it was it
wasn't fair the big places could handle
that the places that are two or three
hundred seats the the small businesses
that they would just I would have to
shut half my businesses down I couldn't
I couldn't I couldn't comply so I
actually put out a post which you know I
probably did it a little hastily and
picked the fight with the mayor on I
told pretty much I wasn't going to
comply and then the next day I even had
a talk with the mayor's office and one
of her representatives about you know if
you're gonna do it you need steam to
shut everything down and then the next
day she did so we never we never not
complied so I mean listen I mean you
have so many people who depend on you
we're all a little emotional as this
thing is is rolling out and we're trying
to figure out how to keep things
together one of the other businesses and
several have been quoted here in DC as
this is happening all around the country
now in Decius they talked about this the
hometown roaster compass coffee laid off
a hundred and fifty of it's a hundred
and eighty nine employees 80% of its
staff according to an email from the
cofounders they say they quote shows the
least damaging of their bad options
opting to layoff workers so they can
apply for unemployment benefits I mean
these have to be incredibly painful
decisions for you to make and people are
making them you know every minute across
this country right now what's that like
well the most the hardest part is the
indecision we don't know when it's gonna
end we don't know how long it's gonna be
you know what do you tell your employees
I mean you're when are we gonna come
back to work that's what they're asking
is it gonna be two weeks it's gonna be a
month is it gonna be who knows you know
it's it's a it was a real tough decision
I mean we were pretty much we shut
everything down so we pretty much what
we were in damage control mode right now
we don't know if there's gonna be
support or help from government we don't
know you know it's fine if they you know
they they want to give us
access to SBA loans but those are we're
just borrowing money we have to pay that
back you know if we're not going to be
able to open for days and months we
don't know where we're gonna be we're
just trying to we're trying to figure
out right now
where were what we're doing and how
we're gonna do it it's a it's a very
tough situation and you know everybody's
in it all of all all the restaurants are
shut down it's not just us and
everybody's going through the same thing
I talked to multiple restaurant owners
that I know in DC and they're all going
through the same you know process so I
mean you are the real-life face and your
employees are the real life faces of all
of these stories that we're hearing
about people being financially impacted
we wish you the best we know you're
going to try to hold it together as best
you can with so much uncertainty Tom
Johnson thank you for being with us